so what we do to change it so you for
example you're on ora TV now which is an
online news network we here at The Young
Turks were an online news network type
Burnley believe that this is the future
initial issue can we reach three million
people
aboard do they get you know it'll grow
yeah in middle goto the
it all balances out up about predicting
the future in this business is
in moon possible they are there's when I
started in radio
in Miami in 1957
University Miami owned an FM station
and at them was considered background
music
I'm who listen to them rate they gave
that station
to the University of Miami the universe
Miami later solar station which became
the number one problem how's the Asian
in Miami if you to set in 1957
a ever miss gonna really takeoff
frequency much
tama right you keep so I
I so I've learned not to predict
right any did okay for about the last
fifty years ago they've they've been
around
so if we can't predict it what what do
you make of the general partisan nature
abuse because to me that's been the
thing in the last ten years
and i were really use it the most that's
one thing about CNN that has CNN has
stayed in the middle
which is a tough place to be Yap do not
hurt them
in a way because everyone is so partisan
any thought not in our view CNN's credit
I'm happy that they have stayed not they
strayed a little sometimes you'll see
opinions
hmm up I don't I see i win
I run by some I always thought that my
opinion as an interview with didn't
count
but I was there to learn from what the
guest spot
I love my ego at the door the name
my show was in them the name the shows
larry king live so I'll be back
same to you i know i a source who what
where when why and the guest counted
on a lot only shows the guest is a prop
for the host in the hosts use the word
I'll I is irrelevant
I don't care what the host links killed
the if
I never if I got a lawyer either normal
or the lawyer
I'm never voted in the senate I never
carried a gun
as weapon in war I never performed an
operation
how could I know more about medicine the
doctor yeah
hunt you're also I might have my
personal opinions on things but I
certainly
value the guest and what that guess
that's the same may not agree with that
so let me come through me as a conduit
you know i think thats lost
so when you had moments that you really
disagreed with someone on here it is
part was the in in moral issue job to me
that the hardest part was admiration
racial issue I when I had interview
george wallace
governor Alabama nearly he changed
significantly
are that was tough and sometimes I did
get into arguments but I found
that in those moral areas when I got
into an argument
what happened was a may have seemed
exciting you can learn anything
it was just two people yelling at each
other yeah and that's effective
but you know ratings are up jackie
gleason was a mentor a mine
and a great man Jackie told me something
you know
Powley always use a POW I had to put
intercourse on television on CBS
Tuesday night three hours I'm gonna wipe
you out
I which you might as well not even go
anywhere else
I own America rate that's not talent
great
and that was before lucy could even put
the bed together so
alright yeah burning of course yeah if
you could titillate this
minded people an appeal to their parade
interest I'm going on the night
yeah takes no town